we're now in the home stretch we just
have to evaluate the curl of f and then
this dot product and then evaluate this
double integral so let's work on the
curl of f
so the curl of f is going to be equal to
and i just remember it as the
determinant so we have our i
j
k component it's really you can imagine
it's the del operator crossed
with the actual vector so the del
operator i'll write this in a different
color just for the to ease the monotony
so it's the partial with respect to x
partial with respect to y
partial with respect to z
and then our vector field i copy and
paste it right over here it is just
equal to negative y squared is our i
component x is our j component and z
squared is our k component and so this
is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to i
is going to be equal to i times
the partial of z squared with respect to
y
well there's the z square is just a
constant with respect to y so the
partial of z squared with respect to y
is just going to be 0. it's just going
to be 0 minus the partial of x with
respect to z well once again this is
just a constant when you think in terms
of z so that's just going to be 0.
so that's nice simplification and then
we're going to have minus j we need our
little checkerboard pattern so we put a
negative in front of the j
minus j
and so we'll have the partial of x the
partial of z squared with respect to x
well that's 0 again
and then minus the partial of negative z
negative y squared with respect to z
well that's zero again
and then finally we have our k component
k so plus
plus k
and k we're going to have the partial of
x with respect to x well that actually
gives us a value that's just going to be
one
minus the partial of negative y squared
with respect to y
so the partial of negative y squared
with respect to y is negative 2i and
we're subtracting that so it's going to
be plus
plus
2y
so curl of f simplifies to just oh this
is just 0 up here it's just 1 plus 2y
times k or k times 1 plus 2i and so if
we go back to this right up here
if we go back up to that we are going to
get
we rewrite the integral from 0 to 1
then that's our r
our r parameter is going to go from 0 to
1. theta is going to go from 0 to 2 pi
and now curl of f has simplified to and
i won't skip any steps here although
it's tempting it's 1 plus 2y and
actually instead of writing 2y let me
write it in terms of the parameters we
saw it up here y was r
sine theta if i remember correctly right
r y was r sine theta so let me write y
that way
2 times r sine
theta
k
and we're going to dot this we're going
to take the dot product of that
with
this right over here
with
r times j
plus r times k
d theta
d r and so when we take the dot product
this thing only has a k component the
the j component is zero so when you take
the dot product with this j component
you're gonna get zero and neither of
them you actually even have an i
component and so the inside is just
going to simplify to
this piece right over here is going to
simplify to we just have to think about
the k components because everything else
is 0. so it's going to be r times this
and that then we're done so it's going
to be r plus 2 r squared
sine
theta
d theta dr
d
theta d r
and once again theta goes from
zero to two pi and r goes from zero to
one and now this is just a straight up
double integral we just have to evaluate
this thing and so first we take the
antiderivative with respect to theta
so the antiderivative with respect to
theta is going to give us so this is
going to be giving so we're going to
focus on theta first so the
antiderivative of r with respect to
theta is just r theta you can just view
r as a constant and then the
anti-derivative of this anti-derivative
of sine of theta is negative cosine of
theta so this is going to be negative
two r squared
cosine of theta and we're going to
evaluate it from 0 to 2 pi and then we
have the outside integral which i will
i'll recolor in yellow
recolor in yellow so we'll still have to
integrate with respect to r and r is
going to go from 0 to 1. but inside
right over here if we evaluate all of
this business right over here at 2 pi we
get 2 pi r
2 pi
r that's that right over there
minus
cosine of 2 pi is just 1. so it's minus
2 r squared and then from that we're
going to subtract
from that
we're going to subtract this evaluated
at 0. well r times 0 is just 0 and then
cosine of 0 is 1 so it's just minus 2r
squared or negative 2r squared negative
2r squared and at this negative and this
negative you get a positive but then you
have a negative 2r squared and then a
plus 2r squared is just going to cancel
out that and that cancel out and so this
whole thing has simplified quite nicely
to a simple definite integral 0 to 1 of
2 pi
2 pi r
d r
and the anti-derivative of this is just
going to be pi r squared so we're just
going to evaluate pi
r squared from zero to one when you
evaluate it at one you get pi when you
evaluate it at zero you just get zero so
you get pi minus zero which is equal to
and now we deserve a drum roll because
we've been doing a lot of work over many
videos this is equal to
pi so just to remind ourselves what
we've done over the last few videos we
we had this this this line integral that
we were trying to figure out instead of
directly evaluating the line integral
which we could do and i encourage you to
do so and if i have time i might do it
in the next video instead of directly
evaluating that line integral we use
stoke's theorem to say oh we could
actually instead say that that's the
same thing as a surface integral over a
piecewise smooth boundary or a piecewise
smooth surface that this that this path
is the boundary of and so we evaluated
this surface integral and eventually
with a good bit of little bit of
calculation we got to evaluating it to
be equal to pi